se habla mucho de compromisos entre
ambas partes para hacer frente tanto al
tráfico como al consumo de drogas
generalmente se culpa o se solía culpar
a los países del sur de la producción de
estupefacientes pero poco se habla del
consumo en Estados Unidos ha habido sin
embargo un cambio de retórica con la
administración de
Bueno
este menstruación
tiene una visión mucho más pragmática y
reconoce que que es un este un cuchillo
de doble fila que sin la demanda de los
Estados Unidos no vamos a tener tanto
tanto droga en los Estados Unidos y
están trabajando para reprimir la venta
de droga prácticamente el fentanil que
ha tomado una oposición muy fuerte en
los Estados Unidos y una venta desde
México muy fuerte y hablemos ahora más
en contextos en contexto sobre la
relación entre ambos países porque
precisamente sobre el discurso el
presidente mexicano ha tenido una serie
de comentarios y medidas contra su
vecino del Norte Como boicotear por
ejemplo la Cumbre de las Américas sin
embargo es su mayor socio comercial como
entender esta relación
esas relaciones uno de Independencia
ambos lados necesitan uno a otro en los
Estados Unidos el tema de inmigración es
fundamental y la administración de
reconoce que ellos necesitan la
colaboración del gobierno de México
porque es un tema muy sensible
políticamente y con las elecciones a la
vista aquí en Estados Unidos y para
México con el socio comercial de Estados
Unidos hablo puede lanzar como dardos
retóricos pero en el fondo ellos
necesitan el comercio y la colaboración
con Estados Unidos precisamente usted lo
decía la cuestión emigratoria es
fundamental para Estados Unidos en su
relación con México que avances se puede
esperar en este encuentro en este ámbito
migratorio
bueno hubo un anuncio muy importante
ayer sobre la migración de venezolanos
los venezolanos ha ocupado ahora el
segundo lugar emigrantes entrando a
Estados Unidos después de mexicanos o
sea más que de Centroamérica y El Avance
Es que la sensación de yopain dice que
van a aceptar muchos más venezolanos
entrando legalmente por aeropuertos Pero
los que entran ilegalmente por las
fronteras pueden ser devueltos a México
ese es un avance y un paso muy
importante de todos modos no va a frenar
tanto porque la demanda para gente de
muchos países entre los Estados Unidos
con mucho trabajo aquí en los Estados
Unidos va a seguir muy fuerte